what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation the three of us are finally gonna do
something that we all collectively in the
middle of a conversation discovered none of
us have actually watched Star Wars holiday
special during the course with dat John Humphrey
MJ Tesla or Star Wars nerd you said you tried
getting through this before you got like what
15 minutes 20 minutes out 20 minutes collectively
okay I've tried I hear it's rough but I'm
going in with an open mind hoping that it's
at least enjoyable for whatever I really don't
know what's gonna I really don't know anything
about it wait wait when did this come out
the year before Empire oh so before Empire
it was a 1978 oh so before all that wow you
know what to do use the force to leave a like
that'd be very much appreciated if you want
to do a full-length Reaction watch along with
us that's for our super sexy rejects on our
patreon we got a sponsor for today's video
can't do the holiday special without getting
response we're gonna justify it in the spirit
of George Lucas himself but guys thank you
again for sponsoring this video guys I'm in
a onesie I've never owned a onesie and my
epidermis has never felt more comfortable
I obviously love their clothing I went to
the Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 premiere
and I even wore the Rocket Raccoon lounge
pants and people would not stop talking about
it easily the most comfortable one there at
the event now I'm venturing further into the
galaxy far far away you might say with this
limited edition print of grogu AKA baby Yoda
cause the child himself grogu has traveled
across the Galaxy and into our hearts and
now you can meditate with him in galactically
soft undies socks bralettes loungewear and
more available in sizes extra small to 4XL
like I said the new Star Wars Prince is limited
so grab this bounty now before it's all gone
they also gave me their shorts which again
is so soft and perfect fitting too even my
wife loves to wear them speaking of my wife
I even got this bralette for her too I said
take it off I'm showing it in the video woman
she loves seeing me in this underwear my Jedi
Mind Tricks to keep her attracted to me don't
work but this underwear is doing the job wearing
it right now I've never been more relaxed
on camera sitting has just generally never
felt so soothing but yes rejection the hype
is real you're not impressed with me on these
your first pair is on the house Seth is a
promise so to get 25 off your first order
and free standard shipping go to mionys.com
rejects once again that is.com Rejects and
May the force be with you always I hope they
partner up with us again because yes
[Music] Millennium Falcon
yes [Music] that's 70s TV frame rate [Music]
I know it's an important day when you're with
your wife and you gotta go to a family event
I'm going to light speed
you'll be celebrating life day before you
know it that's right is where life day comes
from okay
long time ago [Music] Star Wars [Laughter]
oh he looks so bad was this before his accident
I think it was before the accident but his
hair is like a different color for a different
role that he had his wife oh his father itchy
oh kind of looks like my grandpa Kong
yes Starships
and Star Wars story there he is yes
she comes from literally episode three they
literally pulled from these designs it's a
beautiful tree house oh God [Music] it looks
like a sitcom honey I'm home [Music] uh don't
worry there's no subtitles so I hope you're
really well read and wookie [Music]
break up on it he's annoyed it's visual storytelling
Michael come here
get your ass over here right now young man
[Music]
[Music] taking out the space Train full piece
of [__] ingly enough their counter thing
kind of looks like a Mandalorian Forge
whoa lovely matte painting oh it's real shot
on location
oh this is no kid what are you doing wow this
is high stakes oh God I'm gonna throw up I'm
running away to the circus
I don't know I kind of like some of these
shots yeah I thought this was supposed to
be diabolically terrible famous first words
we're only 10 minutes in Greg I know I'm worried
I'm gonna like it be that guy I mean it's
not without its charms time caps exactly it
is a time capsule
cassette tapes on kashyyk yeah
so he must be like old old ah because Chewy's
a couple hundred years old [Music] foreign
yes yeah it is the surrogus that's right what
the hell yes
what are we looking at there were drugs in
that tape do you want to try it that stick
[Music] [Applause] [Music] man in the 70s
this reminds me of like pod people or something
[Laughter] [Music] [Applause] [Music] yes
I want to know this person's life story there's
not books written about these guys that there
might be honestly my Star Wars story would
be about a struggling holographic circus performer
[Music] laughs
[Music] I love his expressions [Music] and
it's really giving it his all I don't know
I'm kind of entranced by what's happening
right now I I'm with you actually turn the
frogs gay I feel like this is supposed to
be programming me to like assassinate something
yeah in a crucial moment when you hear the
right toe and you'll start to see all this
happening in front of your eyes and then you'll
wake up having murdered a whole room so this
was this was actually how we ended the Cold
War we've sent copies of this over to the
Soviets so this is MK Ultra
[Music]
I don't want to do my space chores
this is for sure before Empire yeah Empire
is 80. wow I cannot imagine finally getting
more Star Wars people were not and then this
is what they get that is so funny
oh
look Hey where's Chewbacca
one at a time I don't know what the [__]
you're saying
[Music]
you're supposed to be watching that you are
too was watching that it's literally notified
you 'll hold it
[Music] what's up all I can tell you is that
he and here on
[Music] schedule blink Markham let us know
you're okay I know him and he hasn't missed
a life day yet right it's just taking him
a little bit longer to get there that's all
you'll make it come on tomorrow let's see
a little smile our camel's doing a pretty
good job he's trying
this is a very shrill holiday special it was
a very intense sound premise of it's actually
quite nice now that I'm thinking about it
watch you come around
I just thought I'd show you some of the stupid
stuff those whoopings purchased on me those
idiot Wookies of his Dark Helmet
ICS
away oh he's helping
Greg you're so smart and solo I use one of
these all the time really
I thought Kathleen Kennedy ruined Star Wars
she clearly learned from this
I would suggest then that old popular space
Mrs Doubtfire space Julia Child
hack it but only you know the size of the
fight in your family
what the [__] is happening this is like
a real Slice of Life right here no that's
exactly it I'm not usually plot obsessed but
I'm like this could have more of a plot
this is an hour and 40 minutes yep and we've
barely cut away from this oh my God only 10
minutes have passes I thought this was all
right
get ready strap in oh no we're not even there
yet Greg
it can be is it now this feels so demented
yes
what happens if you only have two hands have
a final report
I got a fourth one
very nice is this supposed to be
that's funny with the ladle right on his nose
his nose their nose this is building out the
culture of it is the post Republic early Empire
inner supplies with real footage from the
film I swear though all the movie footage
looks like somebody shot a projection of it
like it's like movie theater cam footage I'm
gonna have to run back and operate the Afghan
manually stay on things here I don't always
think they're taking you home for life
because you've done it every year you should
know how to do it the best part of this is
the reused footage from the movie
no it's gonna be a more unnecessary television
programming this is kind of like one of those
Rick and Morty episodes where they just watch
what's on TV interdimensional TV or whatever
that's exactly what it is whoa a different
shot yeah right oh there's a little more handheld
it's gritty now Spielberg did this part [Music]
you know what's this for the Ghostbusters
[Music]
han han it's a cultural thing hand is short
for hand
[Music]
head
I'm gonna make everyone kiss you yeah that's
exactly what's gonna happen wow he's very
inappropriate this guy has a kink that's why
he lives
oh look at this stuffed Panther oh it's really
cute I want one is it cute that's disturbing
looks like it's made out of brush and it looks
like a Tim Burton yeah it looks like it's
made out of sticks and like a real pair of
horns they found [Music]
oh Royal typewriter 1971 Edition are we gonna
watch him build oh thank God I thought you
might like this
[Music] wait a drug happy life day oh no he's
watching an appropriate videos is it virtual
we'll see adult content it's a wow [Music]
[Laughter] sorry I don't mind when this does
like this [__] I'm fascinated by this
stuff that is strange Kaleidoscope God the
70s a trip no pun intended foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
no wonder everybody loves Empire so much yeah
the bar was set so low wow this is like a
really low-grade James Bond theme or something
exactly yeah it's like an ambient Bond theme
oh yes yes
this like a yeah [Music] oh we are excited
aren't we what the hell you gotta be kidding
me I never got this far
wow oh I can't believe this is here
[Music]
oh my God this is really happening you see
I am your fantasy
I love that this existence I am your pleasure
yeah
oh
wow you know before this began I was thinking
I would put my head into one of these but
now I'm sure I would put my head into one
of these I would just see you John that's
my problem straight up this is straight up
sexually provocative it's it's more than that
it's erotic he's essential but like a weird
hypnotic futuristic Peep Show saying yes [Music]
it's like a bond song John [Music]
why can't it always be right now this is beautiful
[Music]
what what whoa whoa whoa is that the movie
over there is it a glitch it's a choice [Music]
[Laughter] [Music] [Laughter] she's really
putting her all into the performance of those
no it's it's a commitment she's great see
now I'm like I kind of love this man I started
off very sexual [Music] is going on too long
this is where you're reminded it's a variety
show yeah [Music] whoa this minute now this
minute now sweet
wow this really is psychedelic
who wrote this please tell me it was George
he had it the initials were l-s and D [Laughter]
what is Carrie Fisher not look like Gary Fisher
she's doing their taxes [Laughter]
you mean they haven't arrived yet every phone
call is the same huh yeah just calling all
their friends to find out where hon and Chewie
are
I got this [__]
and a horny Grandpa you come to the screen
please no he's coming to the screen already
look I know I can count on you to take care
of my friends and tell their leader insurance
I can feel it yes indeed ma'am
Now give me a kiss
and do you kiss the screen that call Advanced
and nothing Leia's here yeah and three vo
are here we're laying on the North side will
be safer there
[Music]
[Music] Nice Shot [Music]
they made it Daddy's home did I tell you it
must be Chewbacca now damn it [Laughter]
I like how you can see the edge of the lens
yeah right oh
invite them in for dinner brought to you by
Cheerios the truth of the matter is she had
a terrible fight with her husband he just
stormed right out your identification all
right I said your identification today is
very important just in times like this I just
found my identification
oh I wish he came back he's good what the
picture you're looking at right now it's take
quite a few years ago that's one of me I've
gained quite a bit of weight since then
where's your daddy who is it Daddy what does
he do [Music] homemade what oh you're coming
to catch him to help me gosh glad you speak
Kearney thank you
I guess very trigger happy okay there we go
[Music]
let's go into another variety bit [Music]
where do you get on with it okay okay
yes Jefferson Starship [Music]
all right this might be fire that's Jefferson
Starship [Music] it's a mic saber yeah [Music]
[Music] buried in the mix [Laughter] melting
is Heart of Stone this is like Bill and Ted
yeah I'm gonna change them through music [Music]
I love how there's nothing star warsy about
this is just a regular music video performance
yeah thank you [Music]
wow yeah damn can you get a high quality version
of the song oh there must be yeah you'll probably
get like a whole vinyl picture disc
yeah slap of the best man
[Music] well Jefferson Starship is Canon yeah
boy that's why they had to Rebrand yeah yeah
[Music]
it's a nice choker too I really like this
song yeah
[Music]
set a direct challenge to The Beatles they're
gonna go higher than the diamonds in the sky
my heart sinks a little bit every time we
cut back to this house [Laughter]
here with this instant feeling of trying not
to get bored this up [Music]
dude I like him a lot yeah she came back
release the hypnosis so after this they were
like we got to make the most serious Star
Wars [__] anyway yes
oh boy that's a Mickey Mouse they knew Hidden
Mickey [Laughter] Miguel Raton
damn we still got like 45 more minutes
oh I almost forgot
[Music] I finished the search of this house
we have other areas to cover today it's crazy
how they got Warren Beatty
[Music]
wow that Stormtrooper is freaking powerful
Jesus when my men get angry I can't oh control
them this guy wants a role in the next actual
Star Wars movie yeah he wanted to return keep
quiet good luck
[Laughter] [Music]
has Chewie's son ever come back thank God
they were exiled after this
Revenge
Chewbacca we're long overdue on a delicate
mission to acquire the mystical Talisman which
has been sought by our forces and by the Empire
oh sweet damn come in Falcon it's chewy but
where's on that's how it was
electrician course Dr robot yeah it was literally
like wait a second stand by his near impact
uh-oh what'd he say if something has happened
to Captain Salo and Chewbacca is alone he
will need me to interpret is that Anthony
Daniel I can't tell is that it was is this
happening right now I don't know like what
hot and chewy are doing no this is something
I think this is separate yeah heading straight
for a moon in the Panna system
why [Music]
[Music]
could it used to be sound effects I think
just a few going sir to see the second by
visual sighting maybe wowza [Applause] Luke
shot first
oh no it was before he was a Jedi master
oh that's really cool whoa [Music] I am Boba
fit we come in search of a ship that crashed
near here maybe I can help you I am Boba Fett
and and growing more power ful how far
away
don't you think it might be important to trust
him so quickly sir he's our only chance and
besides he seems like a friend Vibe you know
trend is merely a term that is often misused
did R2 say that works to that event
the Millennium Falcon
[Music] no don't destroy it
damn he knows Luke's name and all R2D2 has
detected contamination Otto says it's some
kind of sleeping artist that only affects
humans walk
only get in the way but if you must come on
I like his personality more than what we got
in the live action show edgy
wow so they introduced him before Empire Strikes
Back And as the whole play and they didn't
Factor any of this into Empire Strikes Back
they backtracked on a lot of it he's only
got three fingers
oh God he does only have three fingers quickly
located the serum for the sleeping virus his
real plan oh no Boba Fett's narrating Boba
Fett
y looks like all is proceeding as you wish
no Star Wars holiday special will continue
in a moment the context is really confusing
me what is it now how are they watching how
is this child watching this yeah and they
made an animated movie based off a real thing
that Han so you know what it Rebels Luke how
there is there's the the space between space
yes they're in the quantum realm okay I mean
this house seems to have like a hard line
into every security camera in the Galaxy so
Mainframe to The Matrix in here
[Music] oh that's a rare compliment for him
to give out yeah so it does factor into Empire
yeah to an extent it's got way more personality
here than Empire I want to keep exploring
this it doesn't say much of anything in Empire
except Ah that's Return of the Jedi wrong
one my bad
[Music] the Blaster is not too far off from
what yeah [Music] yeah buddy
what the shit's going it's like us why'd he
turn into Walter Matthau Ed literally Jay
Leno it's like a newspaper caricature we intercepted
a message
oh it's gonna sneak out of here on everybody
mainly uses you everyone else was very suspicious
[Laughter]
he just opened an eye what
is this face he's choosing to keep his eyes
closed Captain Kazan star log entry 324-1
signing off Force feet with you was that Rod
Sterling no no oh wait a second it might have
been but it felt like it timeline makes sense
Rod Sterling's Canon they're not in here
they're not in here they're not on this shelf
or in this tchotchke this is actually really
frustrating what they're doing yeah
at least they're continuing the commentary
oh no [Music] just when you thought I couldn't
get more demonic wow
[Music]
how The Empire stole life day
dude this kid's gonna lose it rip their arms
off yeah just go full chimp it's probably
like 40 years old and Wookie years poor thing
that will keep him busy for a while mom stucks
a 20 into the Imperial officer's pocket it
was her idea the whole time trying to get
this kid off my ass the whole day
oh that's really sad that's Panther fodder
now [Music] oh all right I'm not supposed
to feel things lumpy is is a Sweet Sweet Soul
sorry you got decapitated
can we play this at 1.25 speed one and a half
we're gonna watch it the way it was intended
to be watched this goes from intermittently
interesting to the most boring shins thank
you for selecting our brand of mini transmitter
uh-huh it will provide many years of fun and
valuable services
like someone's repurposed synthesizer
try [Music] try open because it makes a very
handy storage case for your tools until you
need them again why are we watching why is
this in here it's what it's like to live in
the universe [Applause]
why are there so many perverse defensive personalities
oh don't do it wow [Applause]
it's good character acting in this part is
that this guy's whole thing circuit
yo this Droid is messed up the oil change
so bad red goes to red oh it's too blue
it's crossed over I I oh my God this is like
blunt force comedy do you think this is comedy
it's come back around relentlessly into a
point where it makes me laugh we must remain
alert for
[Music] implication of our neurocranial synapsis
they set this as the instructional video I
I think it's uh it helps you as you go I think
it was just malfunctioning as a sign of their
high quality so he should speak English now
use that man or I suppose Galactic basic or
maybe he'll speak Spanish or something fun
make it a gimmick there you go time now for
life on Tatooine no good to viewers everywhere
in the hope that our own lives may be uplifted
look at all this b-roll did one of those push-ins
this transmission is unrehearsed and unedited
and is hereby begun without further comment
moral value [Music] at least we got this [__]
back megabind hey I love the fuzzy guy
you're right comparing my life to this is
better I want to go clubbing on Tatooine boy
you are not drinking we are
our drinks so the next time I say what'll
it be and you tell me I I can put it right
fine I thought about it a dozen times but
I had to be sure excuse me I have a customer
waiting I'll be right back one cup come back
soon I'll be waiting oh
why does he have a big hole in his head oh
gross that's when I developed my drinking
problem
do you think he uses the hole in his head
for why does he have a mouth
I wanted to bring you something and that's
all I could think of if we're talking I don't
get any flowers I am but you didn't have to
bring me anything oh give me like big Bill
Murray Vibes in quantumania right now
the plight of every female bartender yeah
right what did I mean I decided what you meant
was exactly the thing I needed oh wow that's
explaining commentary maybe that's why it
happened because I wasn't asking for love
anymore I wasn't desperate I wasn't begging
whining groveling sniveling I just came in
here for a drink oh dude it's a 70s John I
mean get it boy
this is acceptable don't do this to me please
look I have customers why don't you sit down
finish your drink have another drink this
one's on me is this how they came up with
Star Wars visions
obviously nothing for there excessively doing
the sound disorder that is Hollow
because I know back soon I'll be waiting you
this has never happened to you before you've
never stuck around long enough for someone
else to leave I don't want any sympathy for
this guy well the entire Tatooine system effective
immediately all inhabitants will return to
their homes at once
guys get some me and these clothes for the
love of God oh man pull up the site while
you're watching this video
over get the [__] out you guys not see
the TV P Arthur shot first
four
do you remember the time the guy's crying
look I'm sorry we are Satan I saw that guy
on the boulevard the other day
oh
what is the musical Prime friend yes it's
a crime friend I thought I was here for something
like that one might say it's a tattooed
it's clever thank you why are you yawning
Greg I have not left the screen though don't
worry they literally they've taken this bop
of a song and turned it into something more
yeah it's clever repertoire expanding slowly
but surely wow that is just straight out of
the Nutcracker movie just a big rat we may
not drive but we [Music] oh fuzz Jeff good
night
song it's not a bad song good night but not
goodbye I don't mind the idea of this song
having the Cantina shut down full of the Cantina
I like that they they always have the same
Cadence and they just change the keys just
a wee bit yeah [Music]
give us a hug then God I've literally seen
that guy at the bar
[Music] head out [Music]
hey [Music] what's up da da da [Music]
all right [Music] it's better if you're giving
Craig this kind of sounds like a you know
like a like a Jewish kind of song that's exactly
it's very Jewish you're such a dear friend
dope next year in Jerusalem the real life
day
oh why not stay here friend
buddy
chills actual chills oh are they playing in
the street
this is a weird place to cut away no no no
was she okay I guess she's taking the flowers
now I've got chills [Laughter]
oh my God I actually played a plot Point yes
it wasn't just random [__] it paid off
there's a mail missing from this household
and I want you to be here when he returns
it's possible he's one of the rebels we're
looking for oh I like that they've been searching
this whole time but didn't know that [Laughter]
it's on a need to know basis I hope this isn't
the guy that's very pointy and shooty
don't
give it away now kiddo Give It Away give it
away now oh no there's literally three Wookies
just rip his bloody arms off yeah at this
point now that you're alone they would have
me murder whatever
oh my God kill the kid that's why he doesn't
show up [Music]
not my PlayStation jeez shoot him in the back
[Music] [Applause] do we have enough money
for the effects no we do not [Music] instantly
better
yes
Sweetheart give me a kiss first it's okay
everybody he's gone [Laughter] everything's
fixed I gotta go heaven have a nice life day
but careful a lot of a lot of chewy chip of
course is clear will you yeah don't enjoy
this moment with your family [Music]
while I stay for dinner and that's how chewy
became a cuck [Music] hi hi everybody my hands
solo Ah that's really nice actually yeah
oh teardrop shoots his family put them out
of their misery
I love you I know
[Music] do it yes grab her ass
started nibbling on her neck oh just a hug
he's even like a brojo
[Music]
Bill Murray are you sure on how to make a
guy feel welcome glad you're home Chewbacca
the amount of people who don't check through
those peepholes calling officer b4711 you
are instructed to turn on your comlink immediately
damn they just broadcast it to everyone two
but before 7-Eleven was here with three other
men he packed a lot of food from this house
and he robbed me blind very well we'll send
out a search party thank you glad that's over
I'd always known he was that way this happens
all the time this day is for you [Music] you
get a medal you get it you get a medal ah
damn sorry chewy I only got three Horizon
Skywalker they randomly gave Chewie a medal
that's so funny a participation award
okay this is gonna get beautiful I can feel
it please do a Wookie song sing it [Music]
this may have ruined Star Wars
this could have been it this has only made
the whole thing better [Music]
happy life day guys in the name of the father
and the Thunder holy spirit amen
[Music]
what is happening I don't care the elves are
returning to the undying lands yes [Music]
Frodo with them
God this episode of handmaid's tale is crazy
who knew this is what it was all building
towards this whole time
thank you [Music] this day better be the coolest
[__] in the world it is indeed true [Music]
okay Chewbacca we were so relieved to hear
you were all right oh Chewie we're relieved
all of you are an important part of my life
pal
I never believed him more I hope that this
day will always be a day of joy in which we
can reconfirm [Music] than anything else our
love for one another Star Wars was never political
foreign [Music] [Applause] worth it worth
the hour 40. Carrie Fisher I love her so much
[Music] [Laughter] contractually I have to
stay here longer you can hit the blunt when
the take is over
oh chills chills
chills I've done it I've achieved chills working
for an hour and 40 minutes but they're here
[Music] this is literally Les Mis [Music]
I dream to dream of time gone by
everyone gets a medal see e3po1
they've established C3 repair and RTD2 as
being having no emotions we are dead inside
they have to look they have wishes but they
have no emotions [Music] oh yeah I remember
the Star Wars movies those are really cool
man super cool movies [Music]
friendly reminder our movies are great a dark
shadow looms over us all this is not on Disney
plus I don't know I wonder why they could
be making so many fat streaming dollars why
are we looking at this footage only a master
of evil though to remind you to watch Star
Wars and to buy its merchandise this holiday
season of course now pre-order special action
figures that won't arrive until far after
the holiday season's completed that's a true
story yes uh the face you make when you realize
you didn't get the medal uh what oh man credits
I don't think so no it never ends this has
more endings than Return of the King
I started off too optimistic guys yeah you
really fell it's only been an upward trajectory
for me yeah it's called character arcs
what did you do on Life Dick what the [__]
was life day
continuing to be alive what do you do on Christmas
Greg on Christmas you have dinner festivities
dinner festivities there were drinks
there's movies
literally and they already go look at it houses
it's called The Tree of Life [Music]
was a man called it they promoted homosexuality
and drag queens and they had a little bit
of everything in here interracial relationships
way ahead of its time we need to see who wrote
this monstrosity let's see it okay producers
take them out back shoot them no Kathleen
Kennedy nah well that explains it wow so many
writers don't credit John Williams for all
the music he did there it is yeah
well done everyone who worked on it Ralph
mcquarie
a Star Wars consultant eh that's literally
what I um okay
wow wow what a time to be alive guys was gonna
stand for a sec yeah no dude hey there was
like it's Humphrey any relationship God maybe
was there an s on the end no but we can add
one maybe no I don't have it yes
hey the Burbank Studios
I was yeah 1978. I'll keep yeah television
no it just slapped the word television on
there oh man all right listen um I have so
many thoughts I can't wait for you to spill
it um if I just walk around the room while
you're talking that movie guy was so anxious
just be like Jesus I gotta get up from this
uh yeah I started off very optimistic it was
like the first 10 15 minutes I was like this
is not as bad as anyone has made it out to
be like I'm like I kind of appreciate how
we don't get subtitles with the wookies like
this is just visual literature to pick up
on the body language and the expression and
then follow it and then they had the weird
gymnast dancing [__] and I was like Ah
that's kind of like hypnotically cool and
then Mark Hamill really showed up and I thought
he did a good job and it was always like whenever
they cut the Han there's like a nostalgic
presence and then I I cannot pinpoint when
it started happening for me but yeah I did
reach a point where I was like this is the
worst thing I've ever seen from Star Wars
this is it if if it is so it's not so bad
it's good to me it got like not it just became
like tedious it to sit through and very very
I like the Boba Fett cartoon I you would have
these moments where okay that's kind of interesting
I like the the sex lady yeah that was fine
she was cool um the the music number was my
favorite part I liked uh not Jefferson Airplane
uh singing and their their music number and
uh Starship yeah Jefferson Starship singing
that was cool Jefferson TIE fighter and then
it just uh it really did become a slog and
um I was like this is way too long this is
way too long this could have this could if
there could have been an entertaining piece
made out of this if they kept it under an
hour um but they did not need to it did not
earn its way that's that's a lot of commercials
this was this was the worst thing I've seen
from Star Wars it easily hands down I cannot
think of anything worse there's nothing worse
Michael I don't care what you say name one
thing that's worse what's worse rise of Skywalker
vastly is superior to this I don't care what
anyone says in one one thing worse name one
thing worse name one thing worse Star Wars
resistance really all of Star Wars resistance
is worse than this yeah this this this brought
some of the best pieces of Star Wars to life
Greg like Boba Fett I guess the mandalorians
think about think about that it's true every
bit of Star Wars that we love can find its
origin story from the holidays what I'll say
is that when it comes to Boba Fett sorry guys
I just got a lot of things when it comes to
Boba Fett um you know I I've always thought
it was kind of hilarious how people were obsessed
with Boba Fett well I'm like the guys on screen
for like three minutes in total and from like
Empire to Return of the Jedi and he said it
has such an unsatisfying death in Return of
the Jedi that this obsession with Boba Fett
has always been kind of laughable to me and
to see him here and I'm like oh actually no
this would make him interesting like this
was intriguing and I wish his personality
was a little bit more reflective of that like
I like what they did with Tamara Morrison
in Nando season two I would say um but I'm
like nah this version of Boba Fett would have
been waiting more compelling to watch he's
not he's not like dinjarin at all and it would
have been more compelling character to watch
on screen so yeah I would say that this this
did that for me for understanding yep look
out of love kashy uh that one matte painting
they got it kept cutting back to um B Arthur
seeing the occupation of tattooing these are
powerful evocative that moment that could
have worked in a different thing I'm like
there are seeds here I see for anthologies
of like Star Wars visions of being an anthology
thing where you have these little isolated
uh things and then something else that uh
oh and like there's the the burlesque show
that we really like uh we'll start you would
have loved that Empire strips back which is
like it's not a serialized storyline that
show and it's not just because there's Attractive
people dancing it there's there's something
really compelling visually about it it's really
enticing it's really funny um on each each
segment is vividly kind of its own yeah it
just doesn't have that but in that they're
at least all interesting and they don't outstay
their welcome and it was a big yeah yeah that
was the thing too is whenever something was
like a tad bit interesting I'm like you're
way you're gestating here for way too long
we need to we need to move on um so I'll be
quiet now um but yeah I I I I really kind
of resented that experience
it sounds really hard and you have all people
I'm surprised you like turned around here
because you had tried the first one I'll tell
you why I'll tell you why context is everything
the fact this made me appreciate Star Wars
so much more the fact that stars like Chic
people watch the tattooing video A Day in
the Life the fact that Star Wars survived
the late 1970s style of things and was able
to like create I mean like you think about
why was it why was A New Hope such an incredible
film it's because every piece of content for
the most part was this variety show monstrosity
that hailed the 80s I would have to say wow
New Hope because this is this is clearly caught
in the transition point between the 70s and
the 80s well it's I think the other bit of
appreciation that I have for the holiday special
is that this had one purpose and that was
to sell merchandise and my God they did a
great job you know what you have bought what
did people buy from this available what kid
would want something you would pre-order the
Boba Fett where they they couldn't give you
the jetpack piece that shot out the missile
because it was a safety hazard so Boba Fett
was the biggest cell yeah but it was also
repackaging everything all over again it was
like I I imagine this came out at a time where
it was like okay we finally got the kids to
stop talking about Star Wars for five minutes
and this probably just like even though they
hated it like like like All Star Wars fans
we hate something we trick ourselves so long
enough in order to to get to the next thing
in hopes it will be better and you know what
that's the state of bargaining because they
believe it's bargaining and denial and grief
it's a cycle and that's what it means to be
the Stars fan no I mean listen guys it was
absolutely ridiculous uh but also what an
amazing time capsule into the weirdest most
ridiculous time period and you think about
like how many things happen during this that
if it happened now people would lose their
mind over like I mean yeah did you see the
way a fan base is already now with stuff that
is far superior to this yeah no I mean like
because if you're talking about time capsule
yeah like you know we we live in a weird time
with Star Wars where there's so much Star
Wars this was the second Star Wars thing right
this is the follow-up to it you hope can you
guys imagine what it must like who's who in
our audience was alive when this came out
and what and watch this error experience of
oh my God this is the future of Star Wars
you know like Christmas Day 1978 like a hush
came across every household in America and
families were huddled around their televisions
awaiting this this moment this incredible
piece of Television only 40 minutes later
a riot broke now we get bad television on
Star Wars and then everyone's yelling at Kathleen
Kennedy and we have nothing to do with this
like it just becomes no [__] story now
one might say because Kathleen Kennedy I'm
pretty sure her first step in the Star Wars
was during Empire one might say Kathleen Kennedy
saves him yeah please John please please take
it away uh I I feel like the main thing that
they were aiming to achieve with this was
translating the feeling of waiting a really
long time for somebody to show up and killing
time while you're doing it because that's
basically what you're watching is just Chewie's
whole family's waiting on them they're killing
time finally he shows up and what are we doing
we kill time we we watched some TV we're listening
to some music we build a machine and some
Nazis stopped by to bother us for a little
bit uh yeah I mean I got some blend of General
enjoyment ironic enjoyment and some painful
enjoyment out of this uh I am endeared by
just the tradition of what this is and to
me something like this I wish could make a
return because I can foresee I can Envision
a version of this that could have worked if
as you pointed out they maybe moved the [__]
along sometimes because that's the thing I
like a slice of life I like a weird thing
that'll plop you into Chewie's family and
no subtitles and all that I can I can get
down with that but what struck me during the
first chunk of this I was like we've been
here a very long time and what would make
this work is if we checked into this for like
two minutes at a time between you know a few
bits so it's like okay this is the wrap around
and then we have a bunch of other special
things in between and I feel like this really
skewed the balance to like mostly wrap around
and then like these little tiny moments of
something either just like I love my I think
my favorite thing is the pleasure machine
because it's because I never thought I'd see
that confronted it's like I like seeing the
lifestyle built I honestly do like I like
the lifestyle and seeing what they're up to
and sure Grandpa's on his weird dance porn
machine I thought that was a really cool sequence
I like the song it was unexpected and what
it sounded like uh and yeah I liked the guests
I agree it was the Art Carney I think he was
he's great he was great I wish she came back
he is the guy who shines out is like you are
the exact right thing where I'm always enjoying
you there's nothing there's no expectation
it's great and then you know you get the fun
of like you know the original cast shows up
and sometimes it works sometimes it's silly
and I don't know I just not want to be there
like I like the idea of a variety show especially
having the animation I thought the animation
you know has aged but it's certainly lovely
for the time and place that it's set at and
I guess that was just the present moment of
what Han and Chewie were going through that
was delaying them on their way to life that
I don't think so no because Luke everyone
was wearing different sure
[Music]
nah John I think that that you're missing
the magic of Life day in your life and Greg
you're the Grinch I'm most likely to be like
weirdly lenient on something like that it
is some kind of real like plot you know yeah
I'm not asking for a suspense or some [__]
it's some kind of real think of how much more
expensive that would have been they were probably
given like they're like all right four hundred
dollars they shot this on the Golden Girl
set or something like that no I was literally
there
that's exactly uh I do have to say though
from the bottom of my heart this was without
a doubt my favorite reaction that I've done
with the real rejects I haven't laughed that
hard in a long time that was rough man that's
the thing is I don't know if I I get what
you mean because I got so bad it's good enjoyment
out of this experience however if I just put
this on in a room with either myself alone
or a couple other people I don't think the
fun would translate the same way have you
I couldn't even chime in on the jokes with
you guys a lot of times
have you gents ever seen the Caravan of courage
no the story about the eve walks on Endor
the live action that sounds like awful I'm
excited we're gonna do it I don't think that's
your decision buddy leave a comment if you
want us to watch it I feel like Greg is gonna
love it is it Canon it might be I count this
as one of the worst because as the worst because
this is Canon Caravan of Courage is better
than this so you've already seen it I've seen
bits and pieces enough to know they finally
put it on Disney plus John territory now no
well that's what does that means this is our
I tried watching it before it was on Disney
plus and I haven't been able to ever find
a good copy so I usually quit a couple minutes
in but uh it's now on Disney Plus well two
of them good all right that's great yeah give
me like six months uh how would you guys feel
if we did a reaction to the Ewoks animated
series uh from the 1980s it was fire guys
was it no no it's not I just had to check
damn I want more slices of life in Star Wars
like I don't know I would love something like
that and a romance I could get behind like
I don't know there were things are good ideas
by this creepy guy in her bar all by herself
no but there was there was potential for that
to have been a fun I think there was a way
that could have been I think totally I think
they could straight up just do a remake of
this yes they could be good they could do
a remake and just do a better version I think
like weirdly I think James Gunn when it came
to his Guardians holiday special did obviously
he's aware of this Guardians very much inspired
his version as he said it many times inspired
by Star Wars and I think he did see this and
go here's what I would have done and decided
like we need an actual plot and let the holiday
magic come to life and it's got to be like
45 minutes no and honestly because they did
the Lego version which I'd really enjoyed
it was fun yeah but that one's actually good
uh I mean I wouldn't say good but it was fun
uh I love this idea though so Lucas if you're
listening uh every year every year every year
Chewy's still alive let's have Rey Skywalker
go on the mission to deliver the little little
they should do what would Ray Finn and Paul
fudgy is all grown up now right I think if
you you know weirdly weirdly for everyone
who's not on board for the sequel Trilogy
if they did a if they did a good version of
the holiday special with them and and everyone
would be like well it's better than the first
one the first holiday special yeah it might
just get people on board I think it's so fun
to be self-aware enough to it like this was
so bad it was shut away like George Lucas
did not let copies of this get out like it
wasn't until Disney took over that it started
to really resurface well so but you know they
could do that you know remember and Roger
Scott Walker when he's like Ray I got to tell
you something and he never tells her yeah
be about that that's such a great right it
could revolve around that could be the start
of that I promised Chewie that I'd take him
to see his family first do you mind coming
we gotta stop off at Kanto bite first to get
some money to bring presents oh and we can
bring back what's his name the the cute little
Wookie Padawan who stayed on kashik uh ganji
ganji yeah oh and and then um you know Ray
could go meet Chewie could introduce Rey to
his family and then they could all be like
oh where's Han he's dead oh what about Leia
oh oh what about Luke CG uh here's he's a
ghost
maybe he can visit Yoda maybe tarsal will
be there from episode three and Tarkin dead
powerful though we don't
have my Wookies all right well what did you
all think what was the sound Michael uh what
did you all think please leave your comments
questions thoughts concerns ideas hopes and
aspirations if you were to cast the holiday
special today leave the number of a good therapist
which which one of Chewie's family would you
assign each one of us of the three characters
who would we be uh hey don't forget to like
And subscribe uh and for you super sexy rejects
thanks for watching along uh until next time
happy life day a shout out someone actually
I want to celebrate life David flev Doran
because flev sounds like he would be just
the most Bountiful cup of Life day cheer if
I had to sit all day and just wait and do
nothing and get harassed I would want flev
to be with me so that maybe I might not want
to gouge my eyes out during that experience
and then we could put on you know the pleasure
helmet together and we can you know watch
our own you know a little song and dance number
tailored to our specific loves and interests
I want to pour a beverage in your head
yeah of course some blue milk in there
oh no I got the zipper caught on my hair oh
no damn that zipper goes deep too that's what
Flint wants for us [Laughter] we love you
and uh no we would trade a million credits
to get you back if Boba Fett kidnapped you
and took you to Darth Vader luckily that hasn't
happened yet but you know stay vigilant out
there it's a strange world love you buddy
love you Flav I need an orange laughs [Music]